hey guys will arnett here and to start
the new Lego Batman movie which is in
theaters right now so when we're done
here you can go check it out
it might be the most serious take ever
on Batman but it should be known that
the Dark Knight hasn't always been that
serious and cool so here at DC
all-access we've compiled a list because
it's kind of what we do of the top 10
silliest moments of Batman first up an
alien device turns Bruce and Dick
Grayson's skin green their solution to
keeping their identities hidden is to
cover themselves from head to toe and
mummy bandages guess that's a wrap on
crime number 9 sees Robin bust out his
rocket roller skates to chase down some
bad guys that's right the Boy Wonder
took the most embarrassing thing you can
put on your feet and put Rockets on them
you've officially found something worse
than Crocs Robin next the dynamic duo
visits the fourth dimension where
everything is gigantic
when a massive house cat tries to kill
Robin Batman yells not so fast [ __ ] and
jumps on its back
defeating the feline with a sleeper old
this is why I only deal with cats who
wear skin tight Bergling outfits batman
has had countless enemies over the years
but none is as hideous as the ugliest
man in the world his superpower being
ugly batman disrupts his evil plot in
the ghastly gangster gets cured of his
ugliness with a bullet to the back and
by cured I mean he dies good thing we're
all pretty people around here get me the
bat Botox in our number 6 an evil doctor
tries to steal the holiday of Christmas
from Gotham as if this weren't already
dumb The Grinch EMD summons a demon bear
to fight Batman in a gigantic Christmas
tree which also comes alive and uses its
branches to strangle Bruce the war on
Christmas is real folks
number 5 next up Batman battles a
guerrilla suicide bomber which sounds
like a sentence straight out of my
nightmares
luckily Batman lifts the gorilla over
his head until the timer hits zero and
the bomb is deactivated don't question
him it's just science Batman needs to
protect an injured Robin in our number 4
so he does what any reasonable person
would do he dresses in all the colors of
the rainbow to draw attention away from
his sidekick
I'll go ahead and file away this idea
for the Lego Batman sequel number three
is when a magic powder transforms Batman
into a genie that has to obey criminals
commands Robin saves the day by stealing
the magic lamp and using the third wish
to turn the Caped Crusader back into his
normal self personally I would have
wished for my parents to be alive again
but I guess that's just me so turns out
back in the 50s people use the word
boner to refer to a mistake and writer
bill finger scented an entire issue on
the Joker's boners Batman even had to
avoid boners of his own which proves
that even superheroes and villains make
massive boners sometimes and finally a
number-one silliest Batman moment when
an evil scientist
Raygun turned him into a baby that
doesn't stop Bruce he dons the cape and
cowl and takes the streets of Gotham as
bad baby I am vengeance I am the night I
am also potty trained wow what an
amazing list an even more amazing
voiceover for more videos just like this
one remember to click Subscribe there's
a new DC all-access episode every
weekday usually involving Batman
speaking of Batman go see the Lego
Batman movie see it more than once see
it three times
God knows maintaining a fleet of bad
themed helicopters and cars ain't cheap
I don't have that that's not a real
thing